jeff snyder here sitting down with the
team behind together together which
makes its world premiere at the sundance
film festival the virtual sundance film
festival this year
uh with me our writer director nicole
beckwith and stars ed helms and patty
harrison how are you guys
great how are you fantastic wonderful
wonderful i really did love this movie i
i laughed i cried a couple times nicole
you got me
wow um and and i just really love both
of your
performances um so nicole for the folks
at home who who really you know we
haven't seen a trailer i don't really
know what this movie's about can you
describe it uh
please it is about a young woman
played by patty harrison who is hired as
the surrogate
for a single man in his 40s played by ed
helms
um and the film takes place between
their first
initial meeting um like job interview
basically until the baby's first breath
and it's just about the kind of
complicated
boundary-pushing intimate relationship
um that develops between these two
strangers
um in this extremely personal
circumstance
and so nicole what inspired you to write
this story did you know someone who's
gone through this kind of surrogate
experience
um no i uh i was just kind of
curious like i kind of wanted to know
what was gonna happen just like anybody
who's watching the movie
and and that's kind of like where i
write from
is i'm just like well i wonder what
would i wonder what's gonna happen
um and i wanted to um
tell a story you know surrogacy is
becoming more and more
um a part of the way families are made
and
i wanted to tell um a hopeful
you know positive surrogacy story
because i think a lot of times
it's um it can be portrayed as like
fraught
and very melancholy and it's like i'm
sure that
exists but there's this whole other
pull on the spectrum of experience there
that's
positive and um and also wanted to
um shine a light on the male biological
clock which
exists and i think like we very often
see
men becoming fathers in film and
television kind of like
dragged into it behind like demanding
lives and
i wanted to tell a story about a guy who
wanted who was chasing fatherhood
by by whatever means were available to
him the same way we tell that story
about women all the time
but we don't we don't see that in
fathers very much
well i do love uh that that scene where
um
patty says oh you know
it's the difference between the on the
single mother and the single father i
thought that was this is brilliantly
observed um
ed and ed and patty tell me what it was
about this script and these characters
that drew to the project
i loved it uh there was something
uh is very vulnerable and warm about
this
story uh and it was an opportunity to
kind of spread my
wings a little bit i mean i've i've been
in serious movies before but
um i've never been um
quite in this space uh and i
i felt like the story at as nicole
pointed out in describing the story it's
very um
it's unique and it's uh not something
that we've seen much of
um and i had a
meeting with nicole and
fell in creative love with nicole
instantly and um and then
i met patty and i was like oh my god i
don't want to do this
uh but then i had already locked him in
it was a yeah it's too late it can't get
really a binding contract yeah
yeah um and yeah and it just was it just
felt like such a fun
cool thing to do um and and patty
it was just such an interesting
experience when i first read it
uh because i think what the movie
does really like
surgically well i'm using the word
surgically a lot today
just so you know just like in my life um
because i'm obsessed with surgery
watching a lot of botched um no i think
what it does like
extremely well is uh
subvert like expectations around
there's like kind of this like madness
on the commentary
of the genre itself that it kind of like
teeters between i think it kind of
exists in multiple
spaces genre-wise and in tone and
when i uh was first reading it
and like literally in the first couple
pages in i was like
oh my gosh are they gonna like are they
gonna end up together is this gonna be
like
this like young girl and this like older
guys another like
movie like that and it addresses that
like within the movie and um
it's just it's unlike anything that i've
gotten to work
on before uh and it had so many
different layers
to it that i thought were like so
brilliant
and nicole so like so funny so she can
do something that i'm
unable to process which is like
like be funny and kind
and earnest where i'm like i just have
to be really cruel
and funny and there's never earnestness
available
that's inaccessible to other people from
me
um and this movie helped i think i think
just like the process of shooting this
movie has changed that for me a little
bit where
um even right now you know all of my dna
helixes
in my body are unwinding and at the
moment
trying to give you an earnest answer and
trying not to like
riddle this with 10 billion jokes
shotgun blasts you with a bunch of like
bad jokes that don't land
so um i feel like it
the process of reading it opens some
things in my mind and i think the way
that it looks
about it looks at relationships
um and like kind of the lines in between
like romance and platonic relationships
and like the connectivity
and or connections you can have with
other people
um it's it's yeah like ed said it's just
something
very unique and i hadn't really seen
that story told before
this movie will make you a more kind
person
i i feel kinder already um and i think
you're actually right about
subverting expectations because i
definitely was expecting actually you
know i'm not gonna give anything away
both of them die a huge explosion at the
end
okay cut it cut that cut that yeah edit
this out
that's the that's the meat of the movie
if you've seen nicole's movies just i'm
sorry nicole to blow this up but they
all end with a big explosion that kills
all the characters so
um uh patty i mean did you did you talk
to any surrogates to get a feel for what
this process is like or ed did you reach
out to any parent
parents who'd used a surrogate to
conceive no
a heart a hard no i talked to uh
nicole is like an in a human
encyclopedia
i i watched videos of like
at home births like the for the birthing
process i watched a lot of
videos um which is like you know
it was a lot to watch um
but nicole was just like came in and
has done like just
this insane amount of research that i
was like oh
okay great she has like such a um
like fine-tuned uh
idea of what she sees for this character
like her ability to articulate where the
character is coming from and kind of
like
not only just like on paper but like her
ability to kind of like feel you out as
a person
and say it to you in a way in a language
that you'll understand
is like it's very scary it's very
psychiatric like she is very smart in a
way that i think she knows things about
me that i don't know about myself
ed what i what i loved about your
performance was the gratitude
in your eyes and that in that birthing
scene where you he's just seemed so
thankful uh that this woman has given up
her body to to make him happy
um and i just loved the way that you
shot that that last
uh scene as well nicole with with the
you know patty's character sort of at
the bottom of the frame
uh nicole i'm curious at what point did
bleecker street come aboard
uh you know because i feel like this
would be a big acquisition title you
know if it was up for sale
at the festival um
i don't know nobody tells me anything um
uh they came aboard after the
you know sundance happened and weaker it
was all kind of this
beautiful bouquet of things happening
um and it's so um it's a really
different
experience kind of coming in with um
distribution
and with partners coming into the
festival experience that way
um it does feel like an embarrassment of
riches it's like
you know you find out you're going
descendants and you're like oh my god
we're going to sundance like
this is incredible and then in the next
beat finding out like
oh and you've already been scooped up so
yeah you don't have to you know yeah
does does that deal include a theatrical
element i'm just curious you know with
the landscape these days like
is this something that bleeker's going
to put into uh into theaters is going to
be a vod release
um i mean i don't want to speak for
weaker um but yeah
it's a theatrical um i think there'll be
both as it is
i mean pandemic or not that's
commonplace now
it's like you know um and i have it in
all my contracts that
that everything gets projected on the
moon i just
and and and automatically plays in
everyone's ear pods around the globe so
i think that's happening just i'm sorry
i started to interrupt
yeah that's how it starts it's like you
know remember when that youtube album
showed up on everybody's music libraries
and we didn't want it and we didn't know
how to get rid of it
right that's step number one that's like
you know it
it's gonna take over but it's gonna
actually interrupt whatever you're
watching and listening to or whoever
you're talking to it just starts
um and and you shot this in in san
francisco right
we shot the bulk of the movie in los
angeles
and then we did a couple days um in san
francisco for exteriors so the movie is
set there
um and i wrote it there um on a
fellowship with san francisco film
society
um and i really love that city so yeah
it was cool to get to go i mean i
really was very sick when we were in san
francisco
so i was like a troll person under a
blanket um
and nobody would touch me or come near
me but even so
it was thrilling to um get to go and
shoot there for a couple of days
there was one day of shooting where we
were outside in the park
and uh it was very windy and cold
and uh nicole was and it's an open park
there's like people like actually like
real people
and um a lot of dogs really beautiful
scene it's in the movie
uh and nicole was directing completely
from inside like
what i gauged as a fire blanket like
or a sleeping bag and she had a monitor
like a mobile
screen inside and was directing from
inside this egg this like very
hr giger h.r giger style
like uh human and embryo
which is kind of like like i think
tonally maybe she was evoking
uh motifs in the film to get us in the
heads
i was becoming the baby or i was worried
you were having some
sort of like psychological regression
into
into a fetus and
i wanted to be that baby yeah
yeah um nicole i know you guys have been
to sundance before patty i'm not sure if
this is your first time or not but i'm
curious
how do you go about making the most of a
virtual festival
like this and what are you going to miss
most about being on the ground in park
city
well i miss these two even though we're
resuming i
really i really um love both of these
people very much and i would love to be
standing outside in a freezing cold line
waiting for
you know to get into parties and stuff
like that i the movie business is really
it's it's such a cool business for
not the obvious reasons but i mean for
lots of obvious reasons but
one not obvious reason is that when you
work on a project together you're really
in this like
this kind of uh social bubble
for a while and it's a little bit like a
like like a retreat or something where
you just can get to know people
in ways that much deeper than just like
an average
office working environment or or some
other context so
uh so working on a movie is i think a
really beautiful
oftentimes a very beautiful sort of
social situation
it often doesn't get a coda like you get
to have that
it's beautiful it's fun you really you
can kind of fall in love with people
and and make great friends and um
but what these film festivals are so
great
at is like reconvening a group of
creative people
and uh and what i love is just having
that chance to reconnect
and uh and build those bonds even more
and this time there's not a lot of
there's not as much work involved
the work is more of a celebration of the
work you already did
and uh and going to a place like park
city
which is a resort town and has lots of
fun resort activities and skiing and
stuff and great nightlife
it's i love sundance i mean it's get
it's it's kind of like
a a cliche but it's just a
fun it's it's a it's a chance to be with
people that you
worked hard on something with and a
chance to celebrate that thing
and i don't know i really miss that i
really
i mean i do feel that that and just in
these zoom meetings and
interviews and stuff i i am feeling that
it's really wonderful just to be in
virtual space with
with these two amazing people but um
but i really miss the sundances i've
been to in the past i
just it's so fun and i'm missing that
personal connection
i mean i will say that i was actually up
until 2 30 in the morning at the new
frontier virtual
party so i'm trying i'm like i'm like in
it i'm like
i'm gonna um be as sundancy as humanly
probably i got up right but you were
passed out on your couch for the for the
last four
hours of that and everyone was still
like is that
nicole okay virtually they like
virtually drew a mustache on me yeah i
know it's
virtual because you don't have any
wristbands or hand stamps nicole
yeah it's true i have my badges over
there though they sent you a badge which
is so nice because that's such a nice um
keepsake and i'm just and status symbol
i'm gonna wear it around
i was up late and it was in you know the
virtual
reality the like new frontier stuff the
shirt screenings the
i saw koda last night at q a so i really
am planning on getting no sleep
um eating just snacks as i'm trying it
you know i'm trying to recreate the
that magic um out of time-ness
and those i watched a midnight movie
last night and write it you know after
the movie ends
uh you know it kicks you right to the
youtube app um so like the way sundance
has done it this year
is very very cool patty have you ever
been to the festival before
or would would that have been your first
time
well it is my first it it is happening
so um yeah i mean it is of course
you know bittersweet i'm not you know
excited that the reason why it's not
happening is a global uh
pandemic but as far as like
safety goes i'm i'm happy that it's
digital
i'm happy that like they're still going
on with it and that
they've made like a lot of really cool
innovative like just like frankly cute
um frankly cute workarounds
uh that it just makes me like feel
really like touched that there are
people that despite
you know all the horrible uh [ __ ]
happening
right now that they're like people still
trying to make it like a
more than just like here's the link
watch it they're like
making it an experience they're trying
to make it like
like bring a sense of like excitement
and joy to people that's really like
nice to me and it like is just cool like
ed said
like getting i i never worked on like a
movie
to this capacity before like i'd shot a
really small part in one movie where i
literally
was like on set for two days and then
was out um
and this is the biggest part that i've
had in something and so like
i didn't realize how how involved
like and how long the process is kind of
like
it's really just it's been so nice
because it's been like this long
like opportunity for me just to like
stay in contact with
nicole and ed and it's
like exciting to get to see it kind of
acknowledged in in this way like i'm
pretty
jazzed and i know that we'll have
we'll have the future um you know unless
some sort of like
insane earthquake eats eats the coast
um then well maybe sundance will move
to like to marietta ohio
all aboard all aboard the buses um i
mean i i think that you're right though
there are
a lot of people who feel alone right now
in the middle of this pandemic and in
this movie
your characters are sort of lonely
people who come together
and i think a virtual festival is a way
of maintaining that that community
um but speaking of the pandemic i mean
we're almost you know a year into this
thing how are you guys holding up has
anybody gotten the vaccine yet
i'm not yet my mom got her first shot
which i'm
she felt okay after super super psyched
about
um yeah apparently the second shot is
supposed to
be maybe a little more like symptom
symptomy i don't know yeah that's what i
heard
all right well then i'd better ask you
guys just about some some future
projects real quick uh while i
have you um patty uh what what you're on
season three of shrill right what does
that
have in store for fans well that is out
in spring i'm gonna keep it mysterious
it's out in spring
okay um and you know i think people
will um be getting to
experience what they what they love the
show for which is like
heart but also like beautiful gorgeous
outfits
and uh and laughs and lots of love and
the beautiful backdrop
uh that is portland oregon um so
i yeah that's that's about all i think i
can say because i have not been primed
on what i am allowed to talk about yet
sure
i'll i'll talk to the hulu powers that
be and do you have anything
it's the final season so everyone gets
blown up at the end
which is really sad i'm not supposed to
say that my nda is definitely i'm going
i'm
in trouble they stole my hook yeah they
stole it so nicole's
suing i'm actually sewing them yeah yeah
do you have any idea if you'll be in
season two of tim robinson's show
i also you know i don't think i
i can say okay fair enough
well then we then we transitioned to ed
and uh jeff i think you should leave
yeah yes yes good one right all right
sorry
and what can you tell us about your new
peacock show rutherford falls
um it's extraordinary it is a
game changer it is
a seminal work
um what else can i say
um it uh yeah we we
shot the whole thing during the pandemic
which
was um kind of
fraught and scary um but we had an
incredible
crew and cast that um
that got through everything and we uh
let's see uh but it's a it's a fantastic
show it's a i play
a um i co-created the show with
uh my old office buddy mike sher and
another friend of ours sierra
teller ornelas and uh i play
a guy named nathan rutherford who
is sort of the mascot of this little
town rutherford falls
in the northeast and uh and he runs the
local heritage museum
for the town and his best friend is a
native american woman regan who
lives on the reservation right next to
the town they grew up together
and she runs the cultural center on
the uh at the reservation and they're
they're just history buffs some events
in the town start to
put some weird pressures on their
friendship and
um and hilarity ensues
okay and i also understand you're gonna
be working with harrison ford on a movie
have you have you had a chance to meet
him yet can you tell us anything about
bird squire
uh i can tell you it's one of the it's
such a cool
wild hilarious script um
and uh yeah we're trying to pull that
package together right now
and i i can't wait i mean it's i reading
it it's like
harrison is the perfect guy for this
role
and humbly i think i'm perfect for my
part
so uh i just yeah i've never never
worked with him but i
i i can't wait should be fun to see you
two together and then nicole
is there anything that you're working on
uh i i know you you know i want to get
get ahead of it
you just uh made a movie but is any
scripts on
[Music]
uh i always have some something cooking
but it's all
secret i feel like i can't talk about
anything
before it's done because it kind of
releases the itch you're trying to
scratch by continuing on so
well what can you tell me about this
amazon show tell me your secrets that
you worked on
no nothing okay tell me your secrets
about tell me your secrets no one's
telling me the secrets okay fair enough
uh well guys thank you so much for for
chatting with collider today um
having a you know good good luck with
the movie at the festival and ed give my
best to mike falbo
my old boss yeah and uh yeah
together together make sure you check it
out whenever it's available courtesy of
bleeker street
thanks guys thank you